metro police need your help finding a
woman that they believe
abandoned her child at the wind tuesday
morning
oracle mana joining us now live near the
property with the details and also
what kind of resources there are for
parents who might be in need orko
well denise police say the little girl
who was abandoned here at the wing
is only three years old she's doing okay
and
is now with child protective services
but metro is still
searching for who they believe is the
girl's mother
we are asking the public to help us in
identifying this woman
metro police say the woman seen in this
security footage abandoned a
three-year-old girl inside a bathroom at
the wind tuesday
the child believed to be her daughter
this video from earlier in the day
showing the pair heading toward the las
vegas strip during the cab ride
the woman did inquire about the nearest
shelter though it's still
unclear why the girl was left behind
metro has a message for parents
remember even during these most
difficult times
help is available all you have to do is
ask
john edsel is the executive director of
boys town nevada a social services
organization for those struggling to
raise their children boys town has free
parenting classes and even in-home
family services where a professional
works directly with parents
they focus on enhancing the strength
that the parents already have
and then providing very quick and
immediate feedback
on other tips tricks and hints that they
can do
parents can also reach out to nevada
2-1-1 other non-profits willing to help
i don't always have room for everybody
that that would like to be at living
raise
but i i try to do my best to to direct
them to where other resources are
available for them
all so incidents like this don't happen
again
our goal is to help this family stay
together
and be the best family that they
possibly can be
we have links to resources for parents
on our website eight newsnow dot com
police say the woman they're looking for
is in her mid to late twenties
and was last seen with a blonde wig on
if you have any information you're asked
to call crime stoppers where you can
remain anonymous
reporting live near the wind tonight
orkomana 8 news now